texas freezes as the power grid buckles
the washington post worries that
conservatives are complaining too much
about cancel culture
and joe biden kind of loses it on
national tv but the fact checkers are
there to save him don't worry i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn why haven't you gotten a vpn
yet what are you doing
visit expressvpn.com we're going to get
to all the news
in just one moment first let me remind
you silver is trending
right now and birch gold our friends of
course they sell both gold
and silver here's the thing we are now
at the mercy of one party control
that means a giant giant tax and spend
agenda i mean this is what joe biden has
promised it's what the democrats are
eager to implement
i don't need to get into the social
ramifications but fiscally you can
expect compounded debt
of our compounded growth of the national
debt a system systematic evaluation of
the us dollar you know who's worrying
about that
larry summers like clinton's treasury
secretary there really is one question
why are you not diversifying to make
sure that you have protected
your savings and your retirement you
need to talk to my friends over at birch
gold
group birch gold group they'll help you
diversify a portion of your savings in
ira or eligible 401k
into an ira backed by gold and silver
they're the premier precious metals ira
company in america they've got an a plus
better business bureau rating
countless five star reviews thousands of
satisfied customers there's a tidal wave
of inflation it will come
sooner or later gold is your hedge text
ben 247 4747 for your free information
kit on precious metals ira or
to speak with a birch gold
representative today time is running out
you can protect your savings right now
text ben 247 47 47 talk to my friends
over at birch gold again text my name
ben
to 47 47 47 to get started okay
so the big news of the day continues to
be this enormous cold snap that is
hitting the vast majority of the united
states we in florida are just waving at
the rest of you guys because it's great
down here but
pretty much everywhere else in the
united states is frozen some 74
of the united states right now is under
snow
or ice it's an amazing thing i mean we
haven't seen a weather snap like this in
probably 100 years 120 years
well the texas grid basically failed
yesterday it
required rolling blackouts now i've seen
a lot of people in california chorling
at this
and because texas and california are
rivals texas is conservative
california is uber liberal okay well
here's the thing
when californians look at texas they're
like ha ha your grid failed
you are getting some of that from people
in the media left let us just quickly
note when california's electrical grid
failed it's because it was hot during
the summer
yeah i used to live there okay i lived
there for nearly all of my life
and every year there would be rolling
blackouts of some sort or another
because of the completely predictable
weather pattern of it being hot during
the summer in los
angeles is that is not the same thing as
a once in a century cold snap
that hits texas and then the power grid
fails see unexpected events
tend to have unforeseen consequences why
would texas
spend bajillions of dollars to protect
against something that happens once
every 120 years apparently
okay so they're not equivalent in that
way let's just begin with that but now
there's widespread debate over why
the texas electrical grid failed the
answer is there are multiple factors as
to why the electrical grid failed you're
seeing the media
run out there screaming to protect the
wind turbines so one of the theories is
that the wind turbines
in texas basically froze over and stop
producing the requisite amount of
electricity
another one of the theories is that the
electrical grid itself was not
essentially wired for this kind of
demand natural gas
was failing because a lot of the
pipelines were not actually insulated
for this kind of cold so
as always whenever there's a crisis
there generally multiple factors in play
but you'll notice that the media are
only defending one of the factors that
would be the wind turbines
now let's be real about this wind
turbines are one of the most expensive
forms of energy in texas
texas is a natural gas and oil state
and so the case that many conservatives
are making today is
what if we had invested more in you know
the more efficient form of energy and
less in the wind turbines
would that have given us enough capacity
to overcome the shortages created
by the cold snap and the answer is maybe
yeah so here's what the washington post
has to say
this is according to will england
writing for the washington post
when it gets really cold it can be hard
to produce electricity as customers in
texas and neighboring states are finding
out but it's not impossible
operators in alaska canada maine norway
and siberia do it all the time
well i mean first of all that's because
virtually everything in those places is
built for things being extremely cold
the climate in texas is generally not
like the climate in norway or siberia
what has sent texas reeling is not an
engineering problem nor is it the frozen
wind turbines blamed by prominent
republicans
i love the media are like no not at all
it's not the wind turbines not at all
you leave those wind turbines alone you
stop that with the wind turbines
now again wind turbines are a factor to
pretend they are not a factor
is to ignore the fact that again crises
usually have multiple parents
it is a financial structure for power
generation that offers no incentive to
power plant operators to prepare for
winter
in the name of deregulation and free
markets critics say texas has created an
electrical grid that puts an emphasis on
cheap prices
over reliable service well i mean texas
created an electrical grid that puts an
emphasis on
cheap prices because generally speaking
cheap prices are very very good for
consumers and that seems to make
a bit of a difference but the washington
post take care is that it's deregulation
that created all of this
because the highly regulated power grid
in california has been such a wild
massive success
so it's not the wind turbines according
to the washington post it's the
deregulation of the electrical grid
system
as though the government would have
solved this sort of thing just right
away
that's what the government is great at
solving crises according to the
washington post the temporary train
wreck of that market monday and tuesday
has seen the wholesale price of
electricity in houston go from 22 bucks
a megawatt hour to about 9 000.
meanwhile 4 million texas households
have been without power well yes it
turns out when there is a dramatic
increase in demand and there is a and
there is a dip in supply the prices go
up that is how supply and demand
grids work one utility company gritty
which sells power at wholesale rates to
retell customers that locking in a price
in advance
told its patrons tuesday to find another
provider before they get socked with
tremendous bills
which by the way i mean should be noted
if these were just capitalist greedy
pigs
they'd be like yeah keep on ordering
those nine thousand dollars a
kill a megawatt hour bills please keep
doing that the widespread failure in
texas and to a lesser extent oklahoma
and louisiana
shines a light on what some see as the
derelict state of america's power
infrastructure a mirror reflection of
the cast that struck california
last summer so the entire case from the
washington post of course is that
the the grid's failures are due to
privatization
because again if there's one thing we
know about government-run systems
is that they are incredibly efficient
and they are insulated against every
form
of attack always this is what the
government is great at
except for not governor greg abbott
called tuesday for reform of the state's
electric grid operator the electric
reliability council of texas ercot
he said far too many texans are without
power and heat for their homes as our
state faces freezing temperatures and
severe winter weather
this is unacceptable he said he would
work with the legislature to find ways
to ensure our state never experiences
power outages like this
again meanwhile people on the right side
of the aisle they were saying um you
know one of the problems here is in fact
the windmills
so for example dan crenshaw our friend
from texas
he said with blackouts across texas many
are wondering what happened
leftists are cheering a red state having
energy problems here is the truth about
what happened
summary a mix of over-subsidized wind
energy and under investment in gas power
means we didn't have enough base load
energy for a massive spike in demand
also texas infrastructure isn't designed
for once in a century freezes
this is correct so he points out that
west texas had wind turbines that had to
be de-iced
the little energy the power regulators
planned on being supplied from wind was
now gone
he says we have almost 31 gigawatts of
wind installed on the grid
on monday we couldn't even depend on six
gigawatts working to make matters worse
existing storage wind energy and
batteries was also gone because
batteries were losing 60
of their energy in the cold bottom line
renewables don't work well in extreme
weather they never will
this is what happens when you force the
grid to rely in part on wind as a power
source
when weather conditions get bad as they
did this week intermittent renewable
energy like wind isn't there when you
need it
two nuclear also got too cold we only
have four nuclear units in texas near
houston and dallas one of the reactors
near houston turned off
due to a safety sensor freezing no
problem with the reactor but the lack of
the sensor forced the plant to shut down
as a precaution
he says this is also a good indicator as
to how safe nuclear is because
they have all sorts of safety switches
three we don't have enough natural gas
online
ercot again that is the texas power grid
plans on 67 gigawatts from natural gas
and coal but could only get 43 gigawatts
of it online
we didn't run out of natural gas but we
lost the ability to get it transported
pipelines in texas don't use cold
insulation so they froze every natural
gas plant stayed online
the down plants were due to scheduled
maintenance governor abbott made the
right call in diverting all natural gas
to home heating fuel and then
electricity for homes
gas and coal brought a stable supply of
energy but still not enough
why don't we have extra gas power when
we need it most because years of federal
subsidies for wind
has caused an over-reliance on wind and
an under investment in new gas and
nuclear plants
the bottom line is that fossil fuels are
the only thing that saved us they are
the base load energy
even if if we were even more reliant on
the wind turbines that froze the outages
would have been significantly worse see
this is the point
and this is where crenshaw hits the nail
on the head so crisis has many parents
as i say
failures of the electrical grid which in
retrospect are somewhat foreseeable but
not completely foreseeable considering
this is you know a once-in-a-lifetime
event
two the the freezing of a lot of the
natural
gas and oil pipelines three the wind
turbines
but here's the question which one of
these things is a solution
now the left would say that the natural
gas and the oil are the problem right
they want
more wind turbines so which factor here
is the cheapest to build
the cheapest to maintain and the most
reliable over the course
of its development and the answer here
is not wind turbines so if you're
looking
from problems to solutions if you're
looking to actually solve problems like
this in the future
there are a few things that you can do
one you can make sure that the pipelines
actually have the heating infrastructure
necessary so they don't freeze
two you can make sure that the nuclear
power plants there are more of them
three you can stop subsidizing the most
expensive form of energy
and the form of energy that is most
likely to fail so when it comes to
solutions the solution is indeed
fewer subsidized wind turbines and more
subsidization of the most efficient form
of energy if this is what you are
worried about
we'll get to more of this in just one
second because the media don't want to
focus on the answers to the problem
because if they focus on the answers to
the problem it might necessitate them
taking a second look
at the expensive nature of giant wind
turbines in the middle of nowhere we'll
get to more of this in just one second
first
let us talk about your sleep quality so
i will admit that my little baby woke us
up at 4 00 a.m
last night she's been teething hard well
that meant that when i got back on the
mattress i really wanted to go to sleep
well the good news is when i get on that
mattress i sleep
like a baby should because i have a
helix sleep mattress helix sleep has a
quiz
it takes just two minutes to complete it
matches your body type and sleep
preferences
to the perfect mattress for you why
would you buy a mattress made for
someone else with helix you're getting a
mattress that you know will be the
perfect way for you to sleep
everybody is unique helix knows that
they have several different mattress
models for you to choose from they've
got soft medium firm mattresses
mattresses that are great for cooling
you down if you sleep hot they even got
a helix plus mattress for plus size
folks
if you're looking for a mattress you
take the quiz you order the mattress you
match to the mattress comes right to
your doorship for free unwrap it
inflates right in front of you
it's great it's terrific my wife and i
have one we took the quiz and it is made
just
for us head on over to helixsleep.com
ben take their two minute sleep quiz
they will match you to a customized
mattress that will give you
the best sleep of your life they've got
a 10-year warranty you get to try it out
for 100 nights risk-free they'll even
pick it up for you if you don't love it
but you will helix is offering up to 200
bucks off all mattress orders and two
free pillows for our listeners at
helixsleep.com
that is helixsleep.com go check them out
right now okay so according to the texas
public policy foundation
they say while texas attempts to
identify the causes of the tragic
blackouts this week and the sources of
mismanagement it's clear that poor
policy decisions are the root of this
problem
texas has lost significant fossil fuel
generation capacity over the past
several years
and instead counting on nearly 20 000
megawatts of new wind and solar
generation to satisfy steadily rising
electricity demand it has been known for
years that a weather event combining low
wind and solar production and record
demand could lead to blackouts
this week that event became reality as
new wind and solar generation failed to
produce when it was needed the most
as temperatures dropped further on
sunday night and electricity demand
started rising
wind generation also began to drop
eventually bottoming out at two percent
of installed capacity last night
and so here's the thing natural gas and
oil was operating at
maybe 70 of its installed capacity wind
generation
was operating at maybe two percent of
installed capacity preliminary data
indicates conservation measures and
rolling outages were not initiated
quickly enough
contrary to numerous false reports that
coal and natural gas plants were also
frozen
almost all of those reliable generators
were operating without interruption
until the system failure just as they do
in much colder climates all over the
world
the situation could have been avoided
had ercot acted more swiftly but it
never would have been an issue had our
grin
our grid not been so deeply penetrated
by renewable energy sources that
contribute the least when they are
needed the most and are propped up by
billions in taxpayer-funded subsidies
every single year okay so this happens
to be the truth
now politifact of course is going to say
that you can't blame the wind turbines
never
ever blame the wind turbines because the
leftists of politifact love the wind
turbines
so here's what they say they say texas
does have a bodacious amount of wind
power in windsor it supplies about 25
percent of the state's electricity
and nearly half of that capacity shut
down when ice-coated the turbine blades
as residents tried to heat their homes
demand search the agency that manages
the state's power grid the electric
reliability council of texas imposed at
rolling blackouts the question is was
the state's reliance on wind power it's
achilles heel
did it fail to have enough gas and coal
capacity to meet people's needs during
extreme conditions
the numbers show that natural gas plants
were the biggest cause of the power
shortfall
not wind the state's grid operator said
february 15th
that about 34 gigawatts of power were
offline but of that about 4 gigawatts
was due to problem with wind turbines
the rest came mainly from the state's
primary sources
natural gas and coal those of you who
have heard that frozen wind turbines are
blamed think again tweeted jesse jenkins
engineering professor at princeton
the extreme demand and thermal power
plant outages are the principal causes
well the extreme demand of course is a
principal cause the question is where's
the flexibility in the supply
so here is the point if the
if the natural gas and oil facilities
were responsible for you know a
bulk of the loss of energy but also are
responsible for the vast bulk of the
power that is supplied
then the problem is probably with the
other 25 of the power supply
right you see how they're playing with
numbers here what politifact is saying
is that in winter wind turbines are
usually responsible for 25 of the
state's electricity
in the middle of this power outage
essentially half the capacity shut down
so it went to 12
12.5 meanwhile the other 75
of state capacity is provided by natural
gas oil coal and nuclear
and of that the the bulk
worked okay but because it provides a
larger percentage generally
that means that the absolute amount of
energy lost in that particular sector
was higher
okay that is not a that does not speak
to the most efficient source of power
it's pretty obvious what the most
efficient source of power here was and
it was not wind
so again the solution here is not going
to be more wind turbines and more
investment into into renewable energy
resources or anything like that
the solution as everybody knows is going
to be less subsidization of the least
efficient forms of energy
there's a certain irony to the fact that
the same day that this happened
the same day that this happened in texas
the
editorial board of the washington post
says that they want to raise the gas tax
right i'm not kidding this is the exact
same day poor timing here
because they want electrical vehicles to
take over the road the only way to make
electrical vehicles
competitive in the in the american
market is to raise the gas tax and
artificially boost the price of
carbon-based energy sources
so i mean the same people who say
that they want to blame natural gas and
oil and coal and nuclear and all the
other forms of energy that are the most
efficient forms of energy
all those same people are saying what if
we took those forms of energy and made
them more expensive and they brought out
this editorial on the same day
that texas was frozen over and people
were dying in their homes because they
literally didn't have heat
well done you can see how the
environmental left is uh really doing
yeoman's work over here
because unfortunately environmentalism
sometimes a great idea
sometimes it has some pretty significant
costs and those costs make themselves
most apparent
in crisis times when the least reliable
form of energy is relied upon it too
much and that is
one of the many things that happened
here but it is also the easiest one to
fix and the one that people on the left
are desperate not to have fixed at any
point
in the near future alrighty in just a
second we are going to get to
joe biden doing a town hall on cnn which
essentially meant
that they did a propaganda hour for cnn
we'll get to the fact checkers and their
their fact checking is really
incredible we'll get to that in just one
moment first let's talk
about a great new podcast raised in a
trailer park with no clear path to
success
kicked out of high school multiple times
faced with becoming a father in his
teens
jason waller is the definition of a true
underdog after hearing the words no or
you can't too many times
he unleashed the power within to start
three successful companies with his most
recent venture power home solar
skyrocketing
on a path to become a billion dollar
enterprise you can join
as waller a four-time entrepreneur of
the year winner shares motivational tips
and inspiring stories and business
building lessons from the ground up he
shares his life experiences
and that of his high profile guests to
help others better themselves
as well we'll tell you there's no
elevator to success the climb only
happens one step at a time let every
true underdog podcast be that step that
elevates you
scared money doesn't make money learn
about failure learn about
entrepreneurship learn about never
quitting or making excuses it's about
risk taking
it's about thinking smart it's about
real raw and motivational
when you listen to stories like this it
makes you want to be a better business
person makes you want to
go out there and forge a new path check
out true underdog podcast at
trueunderdog.com or anywhere
you get your podcast again that is
trueunderdog.com or anywhere you get
your podcast okay so meanwhile joe biden
being given the kid glove treatment by
the media i i have to say that
if you are in the center on the right
you know anybody who actually wants an
honest accounting
from the media right now you're not
going to get it there's a certain amount
of gaslighting that's happening can feel
it churning your gut
okay and what it is is that joe biden
and biden administration will say things
that are overtly false
they'll just say things that are not
true and the media instead of being the
sort of
bulldog media counting every single
trump lie
instead of that you get the media
spinning on behalf of joe biden while
declaring itself objective
and it is maddening it is absolutely
cringe-worthy
and this is the same media that when
donald trump would say something like i
have tremendous
african-americans apart they'd be like
that is a lie that is a lie that is
tremendous african-american support okay
there is no way to gauge
whether that is a lie because it's an
opinion it depends on your definition of
tremendous obviously
okay but they would count that as like
an overt lie meanwhile joe biden will
say things that are overtly untrue like
factually on their face
boldly untrue and members of the media
will immediately spin it away
because they understand their job and
their job is to be the propaganda
outlets for joe biden
because we must never under any
circumstances tell the truth about your
abide unless people figure out
that the man is is a doddering elderly
far left and that he really is not
running his own administration
right we should never think about the
stuff he's doing we should just treat
him as like you know a charming old dude
who likes to play luigi
in mario kart that's really where we
should put our focus okay so last night
joe biden did one of these town hall
events and it is weird that we now
exist in a world where the soft bigotry
of low expectations for our politicians
is is so
obvious and for donald trump there was
some of this right every time he would
give a speech from teleprompt he'd be
like that was amazing he was like well
yeah because he was reading from
teleprompter with joe biden
you get the same things like oh my god
he's strung together half a sentence
that's unbelievable look the old man go
that's unbelie there's a lot of this
last night look at this incredible
performance
he was having trouble stringing together
coherent thoughts but we're supposed to
pretend
that he is utterly with it he's just as
with it as he was back in the 80s when
he was barely with it anyway
so the media's treatment of this stuff
is pretty amazing so here is uh so joe
biden had a lot of things to say
a lot of things to say perhaps the most
weird portion
of this town hall is when he was talking
about china policy so he was asked
specifically
by the moderator about the fact that
china had been engaging in a genocide
against uighur muslims
and his answer was not only nonsensical
it was basically propaganda talking
points on behalf of the chinese
government
and the media immediately swifted is
shifted and swiveled into full-scale joe
biden defense mode here was joe biden
talking about
his conversation with xi jinping the
dictator
of china about the chinese genocide
against uyghur muslims
i don't know what he thinks he's saying
here but it's not good
and so the idea i'm not going to speak
out against what he's doing in hong kong
what he's doing with the uyghurs and
western
mountains of of uh china and taiwan
trying to end the one china policy by
making it forceful
i i said and by the he said he he gets
it
culturally there are different norms at
each country
and they their leaders are expected to
follow
um what okay so what he actually was
saying at the end there is so crazy
that's crazy he's saying you know he he
gets it that i have to criticize him
because we have cultural norms against
genocide here in the west
he gets that i have to criticize him
about that but we have to understand
they have their cultural norms as well i
mean yeah i'm going to criticize it i'm
going to speak out loudly about it but
i mean let's let's be real about this i
mean they they have their cultural norms
i'm going to read the entire transcript
of what he said
okay because i think that it is um i
think it is well worth reading
because some people are going to suggest
that this is taken out of context and
it is really really really not so here's
what biden
actually said right there will be
repercussions for china and xi jinping
knows this what i'm doing is making
clear that we in fact are going to
continue to reassert our role as
spokesperson for human rights at the u.n
and other agencies that have an impact
on their attitude
and then he continued and this is the
part that you just heard i point out to
him no american president can be
sustained as a president
if he doesn't reflect the values of the
united states and so the idea is i'm not
going to speak
again speak out against what he's doing
in hong kong what he's doing with the
uyghurs in the western mountains of
china and taiwan trying to end the one
china policy by making it forceful
he gets it culturally there are
different norms that each country and
that leaders are expected to follow
china is trying very hard to become the
world leader and to get that moniker and
be able to do that they have to gain the
confidence of other countries as long as
they are engaged in activity that is
contrary to basic human rights it's
going to be hard
for them to do that and then he said
that um the issue in china policy in
general is quote much more complicated
than that i shouldn't try to talk china
policy in 10 minutes on television
okay so there it is in context yes he's
saying that the human rights abuses are
bad but also
he i mean xi jinping really understood
where i was coming from because we just
have different cultures you see
and that kind of excuse making from from
trump would be
ripped up and down by the media but here
they're like no no no
it's fine what he said how dare you
point out that it's bad when he says
that
there are just cultural differences that
lead to you no genocide
i mean it's pretty incredible stuff and
that was not the only example of this of
course maybe the most obvious example is
joe biden suggesting openly
that they didn't have any vaccine when
he came into office here was joe biden
last night during the cnn town hall
the biggest thing though is you remember
when you and i i shouldn't say it that
way as you remember but
when you and i talked last we talked
about it's one thing that the vaccine
which we didn't have when we came into
office
but a vaccinator how do you get the
vaccine into someone's arm
that f is he talking about i shouldn't
say that
that trump liberty he's still with it
man okay he literally said we didn't
have vaccine when we came into office
trump says that it's a lie biden says it
and daniel dale fact checker
extraordinaire
over at cnn says biden had said just
prior there were only 50 million doses
when he took office
i'm looking into that claim but he
clearly wasn't trying to claim the
vaccine did not exist at all under trump
oh you mean now you're gonna
contextualize got it right because this
is the way that it works for the fact
checkers when a democrat says something
that's untrue
it requires context when a republican
says something that requires context
it's just untrue that's that's the way
that this works for the democrats and
their friends in the fact-checking media
okay in just a second we're going to get
to joe biden
and his covid it takes so here's the
thing about joe biden and his covetex
so when joe biden says that we didn't
have the vaccine obviously that is
untrue
there were a million shots given the day
that joe biden took office
not only that joe biden knows that the
vaccine was there because joe biden was
inoculated on january 11th
so maybe it was a slip of the tongue but
glenn kessler at the washington post
suggested that it was because joe biden
has a stutter
that this happened joe biden doesn't
make that excuse for himself
no it's that joe biden is not all there
we all know this
to pretend otherwise is to fail to look
fact directly in the face
we are all aware of this that's not the
end of the world we've had a lot of
presidents who are half senile
but but but the notion that joe biden is
in full command here
is pretty wild meanwhile he continues to
trot out a completely
all over the place covert policy and
biden's coveted policy is just all over
the place he's got his
he's unleashed members of his
administration to say that the schools
shouldn't
essentially never reopen then he's got
people out there saying they should
reopen as soon as possible then he's got
his
his press secretary john sackey saying
what if we opened it one day a week and
now joe biden's like well what if we
opened it all the days a week
i don't have any idea what you guys want
i don't know what you're saying all i
know is that i don't trust you
because i have no idea what the hell
you're talking about here was joe biden
disowning jen saki's response on schools
for example remember
jen sackey said the goal was in 100 days
to have 50
of schools open to hybrid learning
meaning one day a week
now here is joe biden walking that back
and just taking his press secretary and
just dumping her right under the bus
your administration had set a goal to
open the majority of schools in your
first hundred days
you're now saying that means those
schools may only be open for
at least one day a week no that's not
true that's what was reported
that's not true there was a mistake in
the communication
but i've what i'm talking about is i
said
opening the majority of schools in k
through 8th grade because they're the
easiest to open
the most needed to be open in terms of
the impact on children
and families having to stay home so when
do you think that would be k
through eight i think five days a week i
think we'll be close to that
at the end of the first hundred days
okay we'll be okay so now he's shifting
the standard again
do you believe him or do you think
they're gonna walk that one back today
my guess is within the next week they
will walk down my back that's not what
the teachers unions want
that is not what the teachers unions
want meanwhile he is again shifting
timelines he now says
that all the shots are going to be
available right he changed it even over
the course of
24 hours he said we're gonna try and get
everybody inoculated by like july
now he's like well we'll have enough
vaccines to inoculate everybody by july
which means not everybody's gonna be
inoculated
by july so he's finally asked when will
things be back to normal
and here's biden explaining that things
will be back to normal you know like
in forever here here is the president of
the united states god bless
by next christmas i think will be in a
very different circumstance
god willing than we are today i think
a year from now when it's 22 below zero
here
no a year from now i think that could be
significantly fewer people having to
be socially distanced have to wear a
mask instead of but we don't know
is he insane is he insane a year
from now i mean i'm looking at my
calendar it's the middle of february
dude
you're saying february 2022 a
significantly different number of people
will be wearing masks and and
and socially distancing than our now but
we don't know
so he's talking about forever honest to
god what's the point of getting a
vaccine if we can't go back to normal
i don't know especially if you're young
and healthy what is the point if you are
20 years old of going out and getting a
vaccine
if you can't go back to normal after you
take the vaccine here's the reality
nobody's gonna do any of this crap
nobody's gonna do any of this crap as
soon as there is any significant level
of vaccination in the american community
meaning people over 65 have gotten
vaccinated and people who are more
vulnerable have gotten vaccinated we're
all going back to normal we're going
back to ball games we're going back to
theaters
everything's gonna go back to normal
because nobody is going to do this
this is not how human beings were meant
to live we are not going to continue
doing this just because joe biden fears
that there might be a covet variant at
some point in the unspecified future
that could do damage
by the way if we are treating schools
this way for kovid we should truly shut
down the schools
entirely because guess what's more
dangerous to kids than kovid
all the things pretty much covid is less
dangerous than the flu
we don't shut down the schools in the
fall because of flu
maybe we need to maybe we need to
socialize and ask forever okay this is
just nonsense there is no coherent
policy
coming out of this administration none
the lack of a coherent policy is truly
amazing
but the good news is that you always
have
dr anthony faucet to clarify things and
by clarifying things i mean
be a complete opaque
an opaque piece of glass that no one can
see through
fouchy i i went you can see my
trajectory on fouchy
go back and watch at the beginning when
of this pandemic
i defended voucher repeatedly i said you
know all of the rage against voucher is
unjustified
now factory is just a guy trying to do
his best now it's pretty clear that
she's a political hack
or at least he has morphed into one over
the course of time uh here's a perfect
example so dr anthony fauci the covet
clarifier the man who speaks truth to
power right he's just given him one
million dollar prize for quote-unquote
speaking truth to power the highest-paid
man in the federal government anthony
fauci
so he was asked about andrew cuomo
lying about nursing home numbers
remember he had said that andrew cuomo
was essentially a model governor
fauci said earlier this year that andrew
cuomo was doing exactly all the right
things in new york and we should follow
the lead of andrew cuomo
then he was asked you know andrew cuomo
lied about the number of people who died
in nursing homes and were infected in
nursing homes
so um any got any comment dr fouchy and
all of a sudden fouchy who can't shut up
about donald trump is like i have
nothing to say about andrew cuomo i
don't know
i don't know voucher here he is
he's argued that his state was following
federal guidelines
when he ordered those long-term care
facilities to accept patients returning
from hospitals
i wonder can you clear that up was he
actually following
federal guidelines to do that you know
jim i can't i mean i'm sorry i'm not i'm
really
honestly not trying to evade your
question but i'm not really sure
of all the details of that and i think
if i make a statement it's probably
could either be incorrect or taken out
of context so i prefer not to comment on
that
well i mean wouldn't that be nice if he
had refused to comment on many things
over the course of the last year
you know as opposed to taking eight
different positions on masks and 37
different positions on school reopenings
but don't worry you know what he will
comment on anthony fletcher will come
out and he will defend kamal harris for
overtly lying
kamala harris said that there was no
vaccine plan when she came into office
it's not true
so here is anthony fauci defending
kamala harris is lie because he knows
where his bread is buttered at this
point he knows that the wright doesn't
like him very much and that the left
loves him
gotta keep those you gotta keep that
credibility flow in there dr
dr fouchy here he was defending kamala
harris the apolitical scientist dr
anthony fauci
what i think the vice president is
referring to is that the actual
plan of getting the vaccine doses into
people's arms
was really rather vague i mean it was
not a well-coordinated plan
getting the vaccines made getting them
shipped through operation warp speed
was okay but i believe what the vice
president is referring to
is what is the process of actually
getting these doses into people
oh weird because if you actually take a
look at the tranching out of doses
what you will see is that number one
states are the ones making those
decisions
number two you can see what the line
looks like in terms of the number of
vaccines that have been branched out and
it looks like a direct straight line
starting at the beginning of january
there was no
dramatic exponential uptick under joe
biden it's just a continuation of the
exact same line
which means that biden has been using
the same plan okay but dr anthony
thought she's super apolitical super
apolitical and the media will defend
these folks they'll defend them until
the end of time
they can lie to you they can say things
that are untrue they can spin
and they will be defended under all
circumstances which is why gensake the
white house
white house press secretary can get out
there and just say ridiculous things on
a regular basis to the wild cheers of
the media we're going to get to jen
sackey the most transparent and
wonderful
of all members of the white house press
corps in just one second first
let us talk about that magnificent beard
that you are growing i know it's
wintertime and a lot of you my friends
are growing a magnificent magnificent
facial mane
believe it or not there are some big
celebrations taking place this time of
year especially over at beard supply
that's because it is february
happy february everyone it's the time of
the year to grow that beard but please
yourself and everyone else a favor do it
in style beard supply running a promo on
all their beard oils right now
buy one get a second one 50 off no promo
code necessary just head on over to
beardsupply.com to get the discount
today beard oil not only moisturizes
away that itch it also nourishes your
hair for a better looking beard overall
so
grab one oil today get a second one 50
off
knowing these are all natural all
awesome for your beard whether those
whiskers are old or new
this discount is up at the end of the
month you better get over there right
quick visit beardsupply.com to buy one
oil and get the second one 50
off that is beardsupply.com if you wish
to have a luxurious mane
like matt walsh or perhaps you just want
a scraggly wispy little
thing like like my friend jeremy boring
well then no matter what kind of beard
you have
you need beard supply go check out
beardsupply.com buy one oil get a second
one 50
off that is beardsupply.com all right
we're going to get some more get get
some more of the gensake show
in just one moment and our leftist media
covering for everything
democratic and like we have a lot more
coming up but
reminder remember actress gina carrano
was uh
cancelled by disney plus and lucasfilm
for the great sin of being conservative
and that would have been the end of the
story normally but we here at daily wire
we are dedicated to
fighting back against this sort of
cancel culture nonsense and that is why
we are now working with gina carano to
produce and develop a film
for her the daily wire rejects cancel
culture and everything it stands for we
are prepared to fight back against the
authoritarian woke left
which is why we announced a movie deal
with gina she's developing producing
starring in an upcoming film that will
be released exclusively to daily wire
members
we've all said it conservatives need to
do more than just complain and critique
the culture we need to compete in the
culture give you an alternative that's
what we are attempting
to do here right now that's why we're so
excited to be announcing our new
partnership with gina we have a lot more
entertainment content
coming for you as well here's the thing
we need your help because this stuff is
expensive to produce disney plus
has eight billion dollars to spend every
single year we've got you so we need
your help
and you know last night we did an
all-access live by the way you get that
when you become
uh an all-access member you get to hang
out with me at night and i got to tell
you the number of people who were
enthusiastic about this stuff
the number of people who had joined up
just because they wanted to help out
gina people get it and i think you get
it too you get that if you want to be
part of the fight the best way to be
part of the fight is to contribute and
really that's what i'm asking you to do
head on over to dailywire.com
subscribe use cogena that's g-i-n-a you
get 25
off your membership today okay also one
of the things you're going to be able to
do is ask us
questions for the all access members we
have a state of the union backstage that
is coming up next week
if joe biden can make it through without
falling asleep then we will definitely
do our best to do the same
if you want to watch that state of the
union backstage that is coming up next
week so stay tuned for that and if you
want to ask us questions then you should
become an all access member so you can
really participate in the fun you're
listening to the largest fastest growing
conservative podcast and radio show in
the nation
okay meanwhile jen sackey over at the
white house getting away with her brand
her unique brand of dishonesty so she
says a lot of things
a lot of things does gensake so one of
my favorites you remember there's this
big scandal where the white house deputy
press secretary a person named tj
ducklow was dating a person over at
axios who was covering
the biden transition team and the biden
white house in the biden campaign
and some some people had vanity some
people at politico started covering that
particular story and so tj ducklow
called
up the woman who's covering the story
and basically suggested that she
suffered from some sort of sexual
jealousy
and then it took them like fully four or
five days to fire the guy first they
tried to suspend him then when it became
clear that the controversy was not going
away they fired him so jen sackey was
asked about this how refreshing jen
sackey and
she uh she said no you know what we did
the right thing in the end right so we
get credit for that huh
i think the president leads by example
and i try to do the same
and uh on saturday when we announced
that
tj declaw had resigned his position
something we all agreed was the right
path forward i made clear that every day
we're going to try to meet the standard
set out by the president in treating
others with dignity and respect with
civility
and with the value for others through
our words and our actions
he's no longer employed here and i think
that speaks for itself
well i mean you know it speaks for
itself the fact that you guys tried to
suspend him for a week and get away with
it that's what speaks for itself
other things that jen sackey said
yesterday this one's pretty great so
she was doing one of these live to
camera mailbags essentially people were
asking her questions
and somebody tweeted at her what is
president biden doing for my small
business listen to this this is the
worst answer i have ever heard to this
particular question
what is president biden doing for my
small business first and foremost he
nominated a woman to lead the small
business administration who
formerly worked there second thing is he
signed an executive order to make it
easier for
uh minority-owned small businesses to
get access to the funding
uh that they need okay so um i want to
focus in there on that first answer
so uh the first thing the most important
thing how are you gonna help my small
business well
someone with a vagina i assume is going
to be leading the small business
administration although according to
the white house press secretary some
women have penises so i really i really
don't know what it means that a woman
was nominated to lead the sba because it
could literally be a woman or a man
i i don't know what any of that means
but it is very important to you
that your small business will be helped
because a person who identifies as
female
is going to be leading the small
business administration as opposed to
like
you know under the trump administration
or linda mcmahon was leading the sba
a woman so yeah real really well done
there jen sackey and everybody's like
she's a the gas lighting i i can't take
it i can't take it anymore and we're
we're in like
month one it's gonna be a very very long
four years with this media in place
because they are
just garbage at this by the way the
biden administration is actually going
to push
some pretty bad policy here jen sackey
suggested yesterday
that they're going to radically shift on
foreign policy which we all knew was
coming so
the best part of the trump
administration by far was its foreign
policy
by far they didn't start any new wars
first administration in my lifetime that
didn't
they brokered several peace deals in the
middle east first administration in my
lifetime to seriously do that
and the the takeaway is all of that was
wrong
according to joe biden's press secretary
what we need is a return of the foreign
policy blob that bullies israel into
making concessions to terrorists
and also kowtows to china and all the
rest of this nonsense here is shinseki
pushing bad policy but at least we have
a girl who runs the sba that's the
important thing
i can assure you that the president this
president does not have is not looking
to the last presidency as the model for
his foreign policy
moving forward uh president biden has
been working in the global arena for
decades
and what he means by foreign policy for
the middle class
is ensuring that our team working on
economic issues our team working on
national security issues
our teams thinking about how policies
impact the american people
are talking and that we make decisions
and make policies through that prison
so that was that was a lot of oatmeal
coming out of her mouth right there
because
that meant nothing except that we don't
like trump and so we're going to dump
over all of his foreign policy
accomplishments now here's the thing why
are they allowed to get away with this
they're going to go with an awful lot of
bad policy they're going to be getting
away with an awful lot of lies
they've done so so far for over a month
and that is uh that is
apparently in going to be the new the
new normal the new normal is they just
get away with lying
and the answer is because the media are
in on it because the media are part of
this
the media are a propaganda outlet your
establishment media are a propaganda
outlet
on behalf of joe biden's administration
the same people who were declaring for
years that fox news is a propaganda
outlet for donald trump
they are significantly worse when it
comes to biden at least there were hosts
on fox news who are critical of trump
when trump did dumb or bad things
you cannot find hosts on cnn who are
critical of the biden administration
when they do bad things
because according to people at cnn
they've never done a bad thing
occasionally jake tapper will ask a
tough question that's pretty much it
meanwhile the entire media has dedicated
itself to focusing in on the thing that
affects the most americans right now the
most important thing in the world
and that of course is the january 6th
riots that happened
six weeks ago and are over and which
trump was impeached in the house for
and he's not in office anymore but the
good news is you've got the media
defending the democratic party
against any and all who point out that
the democratic party
is in fact a radical party that has
backed violence in the past
and the media are working overtime they
are working overtime for the democratic
party at this point so
gotta play a couple clips on this so joe
scarborough
a person who five minutes ago was
chuckling it up with donald trump when
he was running for president in 2016.
he was getting together with him he and
mika they were watching they were
watching debates together it was all
good times for
joe scarborough then scarborough decided
that trump was the fonte head of all
evil
now joe scarborough is saying that there
is no way to criticize the black lives
matter riots of the summer
in comparison with the capital attack
the level of
elitism that is implicit in this
commentary is pretty astonishing
let's just listen to what scarborough
has to say because this does reflect
what many in the media think and it is
so dismissive of the concerns of tens of
millions of americans
here is joe scarborough saying you can
never ever ever point out that there's
violence on both sides of the aisle and
that many mainstream figures
on the left side of the aisle have given
the go-ahead to violence you can't do
that here's joe scarborough
i know they're idiots on other cable
news channels
that will will say well you know this
mom and pop store
was vandalized during the summer riots
and that's just as bad
as the united states capital being
vandal no
no actually no no jackass it's not
the capital of the united states of
america is the center of american
democracy
and while i am a fierce believer in
people's right to defend their private
property
i'm not going to confuse a taco stand
with the united states capital see the
taco stand is just something that you
personally invested in and built a
business yourself and if somebody burns
that down i mean that's not that big a
deal if they attack a taxpayer building
and then the taxpayer building
immediately gets cleaned by a crew
and is defended by you know police
officers and everything then that's much
like why do we care about your taco
stand again i'm just confused
how about this how about both things are
bad i mean why can't we just say that
like people invading the capitol
building is a tremendous act of evil you
know what else is in active people
burning down a guy's taco stand that is
an act of evil it is absolute evil to
burn down somebody's private property
because you are pissed about an
unrelated issue or because you're just
taking advantage of the chaos
surrounding that unrelated issue to do
damage to somebody by the way it wasn't
just a taco stand joe
the black lives matter riots did two
billion dollars in damage
two billion dollars according to
insurance estimates it was the single
most
damaging spate of rioting in american
history what happened over the summer
the amount of property damage done at
the capitol was far less than that
that's not to minimize what happened at
the capitol on an ideological level it
was an act of evil as an attempt to
overthrow
the the workings of democracy it failed
it failed that day
it didn't go on for months it didn't
have massive support from the political
infrastructure
there's a bunch of nut cases deciding
they were going to run into the capital
building and act like jackasses and
photograph themselves and put it on
instagram so they can get arrested later
that's not to downplay the evil but i'm
not the one down playing evil here it's
joe scarborough who's down playing evil
if you burn down a dude's taco stand
apparently that just doesn't rank
in the list of priorities because for
the media the only thing that matters is
what they do for a living and that is
covering the government
and the government is the only thing
that matters because they cover it
so if your property got burned down no
biggie and if democrats back that
no biggie again don lemon making that
point he says listen you know kamala
harris sure she raised money for
writer's legal fees but that's not a big
deal
by the way don lemon portraying himself
as an objective journalist you could
switch out the transcripts of joy
readings on lemon they would read
exactly the same
joy read at least doesn't present
herself as objective don lemon does
so here is don lemon suggesting that
it's perfectly fine for kamal harris to
raise money for rioters legal fees
because it's legal it's okay because
here's the thing
they don't care if your business gets
burned down all they care about
is their political point of view all
they care about is the stuff that is
important to them
now the stuff that's important to them
can be important but the stuff that's
important to you
is also important and by the way has a
much more dramatic impact on your life
if somebody burns down your store that
has a much more
dramatic personal impact on you than a
bunch of yahoo jackasses running into
the capitol building and breaking some
windows
in terms of personal impact you not in
terms of impact on the country at large
in terms of personal impact on you and
you know it has a big impact on the
country as well
when a bunch of political figures and
members of media say it's okay to burn
down your taco stand
the dismissive and derisive tone toward
people who run businesses in this
country and who have invested their life
savings in those businesses and who want
to live in peace and security in their
in their communities the dismissive tone
is astonishing here is here is
don lemon defending kamala is bailing
out rioters
after the police killing of george floyd
in minneapolis last spring
thousands of people including black
lives matter supporters took
to the streets kamala harris tweeted
support for donations to the minnesota
freedom fund which helped people post
bail if they were arrested
while protesting so let's hit the record
straight there was no
bailing out right kamala harris
tweeted about a fund
to help people post bail which is
entirely
legal okay so um no that's called
bailing out if i post a donation link to
a bailing out people fund
and those people are not generally
arrested for protesting because
protesting is
legal and the people who are in jail
were rioting
they were committing crimes that is why
they had been arrested in the first
place
but according to don lemon that's
totally fine why is it totally fine
because he agrees with those people
because he thinks that those people are
doing something that is just and noble
and so it's fine
by the way i will point out to don lemon
you know what else is legal perfectly
legal the president of the united states
saying untrue things about an election
and telling people to peacefully and
patriotically march to protest at a
capital
that is perfectly legal i don't think
that was don lemon's perspective on
donald trump's behavior
on january 6th do you the utter
imbalance in the media
is going to be the continuing issue of
our time and it's not going away
you want to talk about the the fact that
we live in two different universes when
it comes to the facts it's because
there's
an entire industry that is dedicated to
lying
okay to telling a to telling a narrative
that is different from the fact and
defending people
who agree with that narrative now we've
tried on this show to differentiate
between things that are
fact and things that are my opinion i
try to do that every single day
i've said things that many of my
listeners disagree with because i think
that it's important for you to know the
difference between my opinion and
something that is factual members of our
media they don't care and i'm honest
with you about my own biases don lemon
is not
hey that imbalance is creating the
massive distrust of institutions and no
that distrust of institutions is not
going to go away
it's not going to go away anytime soon
and that is why you're starting to see
the left get more and more authoritarian
the left realizes that in order for them
to have a prevailing point of view here
in order to end the polarization there
are only two ways to do it one is to
come back to the table they don't want
to do that
the and start being honest they're not
going to do that and the other is just
to purge
the other is to cram down their
particular point of view through woke
purges
speaking of which let's talk about the
cancel culture for a moment so one of
the greatest forms
of gaslighting that's happening in our
society right now is this push by the
left to cancel people to destroy their
careers to go to people's bosses to get
them fired
to destroy their livelihoods to get them
kicked out of schools based on old media
media posts or misinterpreted comments
and then and then to say that's not
happening it's not
cancelled culture is just consequences
for your actions guys that's all
cancelled culture is
well the question is are the
consequences calibrated to the crime
or was there even a crime committed
that's what we mean by cancel culture
nobody is deeply worried about you
speaking out against somebody you
disagree with
that ain't cancelled culture you know
what is canceled culture going to their
employer and getting them fired
for saying something online that you
didn't like unrelated to their job
that's cancelled culture and you guys
are pushing it every single day
but here's the thing the left has pushed
too far the authoritarian left which has
taken over nearly every institution of
american life
we're talking about from corporate
america which is now cramming down
bullcrap diversity
woke training sessions on you to
hollywood which has determined that if
you're a conservative you cannot work
there and also they're only going to
produce films
that transform one political side of the
aisle and tv shows that trend toward one
political side of the aisle
whether you're talking about the
scientific community which has caved in
large measure
to the woke there are scientific
journals that now ban studies i'm not
getting this
about this there's scientific journals
that ban studies if those studies have
quote unquote disparate impact
you're not allowed to publish a study if
people could use the study to push for
policy that is not in conjunction with
leftist
points of view every place from science
to hollywood to corporate america
every place from government to
universities
the authoritarian left is in control of
the means of dissemination of
information
and they are in control of millions of
people who work every single day in this
country and pay taxes
they're in control of their lives and so
what the left is afraid of
very much is that the authoritarian left
which does not represent a majority in
this country
the local authoritarian left which loves
canceling people and makes life
miserable
and wishes to eliminate all jokes and
all fun and wants to keep chat tabs on
clubhouse and wants to keep tag on tabs
on facebook and twitter
and make sure that they're watching you
every minute of every day to make sure
you don't say
anything that they don't agree with
those people are annoying
they are puritan they are mccarthyist
and nobody likes them
okay but they have created a power
structure at the top of these
institutions
by being what is called an intransigent
minority in social science talk
so i've talked before on the show about
renormalization the process of
renormalization is how you take over an
organization
so if you want to take over an
organization it does not require you to
have a majority of the stock in a
corporation to take over the corporation
from the inside for example
all it requires is about 20 of people to
agree that they are not going to go
along with an agenda item
and the other 80 of people to be kind of
wishy-washy about it or silenced
that's all it requires renormalization
is pretty easy to make happen
the example that i've used before is an
example that uh that is taken
from a nicholas nassim taleb which is
the the example of a
vegan daughter in a meat-eating home
right the vegan daughter says to mom
listen you guys can make whatever meal
you want i'm only eating vegan tonight
now mom has two choices she can either
make two meals one for the vegan
daughter and one for everybody else
or she can make one meal a vegan meal
for everybody
and so the entire family is now eating
vegan now that family goes to a street
barbecue and they say listen
we vegan now because of our daughter we
need you to
either serve us vegan and serve
everybody else barbecue or everybody can
eat vegan
and so the neighbor is only inviting
four families they're like that's a lot
of hassle i'm just gonna order out vegan
for everybody
because why waste the extra money it's
too much now you've taken one person and
i got 16 or 20 people who are all eating
vegan because of this one person
right renormalization is not hard to
make happen well in the world of the
institutions this is what the
authoritarian left has done
they have said we are not going to work
in the same corporations as you
if you do x right if you say x we're not
going to work with you
and we're going to to our bosses
and we're going to threaten lawsuits
and so the bosses they say you know what
it's not worth the hassle
just tell everybody to shut up you
should buy a diversity training manual
from ibram kendy and
maybe these people will silence and and
go away and so all the
all of these institutions are
essentially held hostage now here's the
problem for the people who are taking
over the institutions
again they remain a minority within
their own institutions nobody likes them
but there's no solidarity and
cohesiveness to the resistance to this
phenomenon
right the the other eighty percent of
people who don't like this kind of crap
they are not getting together and saying
listen we're gonna fight back against
this
so now now we here at the daily wire and
a lot of people on the right we're
starting to fight back against this
many of us are saying you know what
we're not okay with this and we gotta
get together and reject this
do not cave to the cancel culture mob do
not listen to them fight back tell your
employer that you're not going to work
with that guy if he wants to cancel you
tell him that you and 80 of your and
your colleagues are not going to listen
to robin d'angelo spew bullcrap to you
about how being white is inherently
supremacist
and if you do that you can actually
re-normalize the institutions you can
return them to normal
so here's what have the left is fighting
that now they're fighting it with
gaslighting they say yeah we understand
that we've re-normalized the
institutions we understand that we are
using authoritarian measures from the
top down
in order to cram down our particular
point of view but it's all in your head
it's all in your head cancel culture is
both good but it's also in your head
it's a perfect example of the genre
today philip bump has a piece of the
washington post
and he's very very upset that people on
the right are noticing cancel culture
if you notice it here's the problem if
you notice cancel culture you fight back
against it
and there are enough of us to fight back
against cancer culture that they can't
succeed
and the authoritarian left lose their
foothold of control so instead
he has to say no no you guys you're not
being canceled you see you're just being
full victims so here's philip bump at
the washington post today
quote one of the best encapsulations of
the past few years of politics came from
president donald trump about a month
after he lost his re-election bid last
year
quote we're all victims he told an
audience at a rally december 5th in
georgia
everybody here all these people here
tonight they're all victims every one of
you
now he was talking about voter fraud he
said they were victims of voter fraud
which wasn't true but
bump is going to use this as the jumping
off point quote this sentiment was
central to trump's appeal to many
republican voters
in the 2016 election a sense that white
americans were losing out in modern
society was a better predictor of
support for trump than economic
disadvantage
trump voters more than anyone else saw
racism against whites as a potent
problem
and were more likely to view whites as
victims of discrimination at rates
similar to racial and ethnic minorities
trump promised to make america great
again to wind back the clock to a time
before things such as black lives matter
to a time when the distributions of the
rewards of american society weren't
questioned you see the reframing here
the reframing here is that if you just
want to be treated as an individual it's
really because you're in favor of white
supremacy and you don't want the
hierarchies of power to be torn down
that's the reframing now all of that
that entire line of attack
is replete in the cancel culture
right if i stand up for individual
liberty and the meritocracy it's because
i'm secretly a racist and i should be
canceled for saying these sorts of
things
folks on the left are not on the
authoritarian left they are not shy
about saying this sort of stuff the boom
kenny says it all the time
philip bump continues it's hard to
articulate the sentiment explicitly
though particularly to a group of
americans who are at the same time
hyping their profane indifference to
feelings
and hawking mugs to hold liberal tears
right this of course
is a rip on us how do how dare we say
that we are
we are not in favor of feelings it's
coded packaged in other ways
such as the framing offered by del
delawa delegate kirk cox
republican of virginia a candidate for
governor in the state quote there's been
so much silencing and shaming because of
cancelled culture it's gone too far
he said in an ad released on twitter we
can't even have a competition of ideas
and for representative democracy to work
you have to have that
the left simply cannot be allowed to
ignore other opinions so i as governor
will not stand for that
okay now there's nothing wrong with that
sentiment but philip bump is gonna say
that it's racist and paranoid to point
out that people are being silenced
which is his attempt to silence people
ironically he says cancel culture
as you may be aware is an umbrella term
for incidents in which people usually
public figures have faced blowback for
comments or actions
generally ones seen as culturally
inappropriate it's a nebulous phrase
your definition may vary but it centers
on the idea that some people have been
canceled
exiled from society for their views cox
obviously sees this as a politically
potent position to take
and that we're mentioning it seems to
bolster that idea but so does a poll
from the huffington post released on
tuesday
conducted by yougov it found that while
only half the country was familiar with
the term the vast majority of
republicans familiar with it see cancel
culture
as somewhat or very serious as a problem
since a similar poll conducted in
september the percentage of trump voters
familiar with the term who say cancel
culture is a very serious problem
increased by 14 percentage points
if you're seeking a republican
nomination amplifying those concerns
seems to be warranted okay but this is
bad
but this is bad according to philip bump
right because cancel culture is a
concept predicated on categorizing
particular views as verboten
and those views are often ones that
overlap with the sense that whites and
men are imperiled
this is by no means always true some
concern about canceled culture also also
derives from social media bans but it's
often the case says philip bump
of the washington post that the concern
expressed as part of the backlash to the
perceived phenomenon
is the same concern that trump expressed
to applause during his first primary
republican debate
in august 2015. his obnoxious comments
about women were simply a mark that he
wouldn't behold into a politically
correct
world view and then he talks about why
cancel culture is good
right because cancel culture is about
canceling the people that we don't like
and we like canceling those people so
if you don't go along with that it's
because you have adopted a victimhood
mentality says philip bump
he says concern about cancel culture is
an explicit manifestation of
victimization by those who see
themselves as a focus of questions about
accountability and power
the message is that cultural elites
including the media are trying to
silence opposing views
but it's often a convenient claim none
of this is that simple that too
is the point conflating all criticism
into some big brother-esque effort at
silencing half the country
is a facile approach to the moment which
of course is why it's appealing to
political
actors okay this entire column is
basically saying that if you're worried
about the council culture it's because
you're a white supremacist
also stop worrying about the council
culture
it's amazing but this is the perspective
of the left this is how they're going to
cuddle people into silence so here's the
answer don't be cuddled into silence
don't apologize don't be cuddled into
silence the left knows this crap works
they know it works
okay let me read you a quote from the
hollywood reporter this is pretty
amazing so hollywood reporter
was reporting about the firing of
mandalorian sergina carano who is now
over here with us over at daily wire
producing
and starring in a film okay the
hollywood reporter has a long piece
about why carano
was tossed from lucasfilm there's one
quote in this piece
that is particularly relevant it is from
a crisis pr representative named judah
engelmeyer
quote i don't know what people at disney
personally believe or don't believe with
regard to politics but as a corporate
entity they want to stay as trouble free
as possible
and anything that's going to offend the
left is a problem
i have clients who are making an
extraordinary effort to post what the
social left
wants to see okay it's perfectly obvious
what's going on here
right it's happening in every aspect of
our culture you're not wrong
to feel that you are under attack
because you are under attack
from all of the institutions that have
been hijacked by the by the
authoritarian left and then covered for
by the by the mainstream establishment
media that love this kind of stuff
because it puts them in the driver's
seat in american life
and you can see the extent of this right
bachelor stars are now coming out is a
great example of the bachelor stars are
now coming out and saying that chris
harrison must be fired
and major changes must be must be made
to address the bachelor's
racism is according to emily's inaudible
culture story of the last few weeks
okay it's insane chris harrison didn't
even post anything controversial
chris harrison is the host of the
bachelor there was a woman on the
bachelor who
by the way is competing for the
affections of a man who happens to be
black and this woman
several years ago attended an old south
party in which she dressed up
in an old south dress this in and of
itself was deemed racist
then harrison said you know what i'm not
the woke police
and the reality is we should treat
people with some grace and let her
explain herself
this was deemed second degree racist
right we now have first degree racism
which is you did it yourself and then we
have second degree racism
which is that you said a not racist
thing in favor of a person
who might or might not have done a
racist thing right so we are now
second-degree racism
okay and and so harrison apologized for
having said we might need to show people
some grace
by the way you know who said the same
thing the bachelor star he said the same
thing but because he's black we ignore
that
and because harrison is white this means
that he is covertly a white supremacist
he's being accused of perpetuating
racism for speaking out against canceled
culture
and saying that she should be allowed to
explain herself this particular
contestant
rather than face a judge jury and
executioner on social media
so now old members of the bachelor are
coming out
and and saying that they are that they
want harrison axed permanently
demario jackson and jubilee sharp two
alumni of the bachelor program
said that harrison should lose his job
jubilee shared that during her time on
the show according to tmz she noticed
that white contestants were treated
better by producers
demario told the site the franchise
needs to make major changes in order to
deflect further charges of racism
jackson said it just sucked because yeah
we had each other but there was nobody
we could really relate to because it was
an all-white production all-white cast
all-white show which is great but it's
2021 now
women who took part in the 25th season
of the bachelor released their own
statement
demanding better treatment for black
indigenous people of color contestants
without naming harrison specifically and
announced the host for defending
quote-unquote racist behavior they said
we denounced any defense of racism
these experiences are not to be
exploited or tokenized
okay so our mainstream establishment
media the people who of course
are standing up for your right to speak
freely people like don lemon
so don lemon hosts bachelorette star
rachel lindsay now recognize harrison
said this
on rachel lindsay's podcast i believe
and rachel lindsay got very offended
because she is a former contestant
uh she was the the star of the
bachelorette and she of course is black
so she's on with don lemon and they just
spent a segment
ripping into chris harrison for not
being a racist but don't worry guys
cancel culture isn't real it's all in
your head and you're just thinking
that uh you're victimized because you're
a white supremacist
so you should be canceled but cancel
culture isn't real because you're
complaining about it
because you're a white supremacist and
you should be cancelled but canceled
culture isn't real
here just keep repeating it over and
over until it makes sense here's don
lemon with rachel lindsay going after
chris harrison by the way
uh producer savvy suggests that the play
here is going to be that they eventually
make
rachel lindsey the host of the bachelor
which
would be the most perfectly predictable
move i i think it's a good call by savvy
here is a don lemon and the bachelorette
star rachel lindsay going after chris
harrison for the great crime of saying
that people deserve grace
why do you think chris harrison was
willing to give rachel kirk connell so
much room for
her hurtful actions yet couldn't muster
an empathy towards communities
of color who were offended well i think
that's the problem in our society is
that
people aren't trying to understand the
other side he knew how to defend himself
and what he represents he hasn't taken
the opportunity or the chance
in almost 50 years especially doing what
he does in the history of this show
to learn about racism and america
that's actually the definition of
privilege he's a white privileged man
because he has been cancelled
from the show for the great crime of
saying that people should be treated
decently
and not mobbed by social media and don
lemon is pushing that forward but don't
you worry about cancel culture it's not
coming for you
i mean it is but it's not real and when
it does come for you if you complain
about it it's because you're
a privileged white person and you should
be wrecked but don't worry we're not
canceling you because
it's just what you deserve okay the
authoritarian left can be stood up to
the biggest mistake here is that chris
harrison apologized he never should have
apologized you should have told them to
stick
to stick it you should have told them to
stick it the way the gina carano told
them to stick it and more and more
people in hollywood
in business we all need to do this
together there needs to be a solidarity
among those of us who wish to have open
debate and discussion
and not buy into a culture that says
your life should be ruined because you
said something that crosses the
priorities
of the woke left but again the game of
the media here is to pretend that you
are a bad person for even noticing the
bad thing they are doing to you
you are the problem well here's the
thing you're not the problem they're the
problem and we all need to stand up and
fight back against this nonsense
okay a quick note here on rachel lindsay
because i've just been informed of this
by producer savvy who's on top of these
things i mean
she really knows i don't know what she
does the rest of her day honestly but in
any case
she let me know about this yesterday so
rachel lindsay right who you saw and
heard in that clip with don lemon
talking about
the awful evil chris harrison who
committed the great sin of saying that
people deserve grace
and they shouldn't be wrecked on social
media um let me just say if a white
person did what rachel lindsay did on
her instagram
just a few months ago that person would
have been destroyed like their career
would be over
because here's what rachel lindsay did a
few months ago okay in the middle
of the black lives matter protest she
tweeted out a picture of herself
in front of i kid you not a cadillac
xt6 and here's what she wrote quote
we are living in unprecedented times
right now i know we cannot escape our
reality but we do what is necessary to
take care of ourselves physically and
mentally
for me i like to clear my head by going
for a drive in my cadillac xt6
with its bluetooth connectivity i can
easily connect to my phone to stream
almost anything
and everything with crystal clear audio
on the standard bose speaker system
i can take this time to listen and learn
from podcasts that support and uplift
black voices it is so important that we
take the time to understand
what and why things are happening in our
country what are some of your favorite
podcasts that discuss these issues
share your recommendations in the
comments and tell me how you're doing
your part to share some good
these days hashtag ad cadillac community
cadillac escapes be the good
so um there's some privilege happening
right here
uh it ain't chris harrison i think that
we can call you privileged
if you are literally cutting an ad for
cadillac
while talking about uplifting black
voices by listening to podcasts
in your brand new cadillac xtx xt
xd6 with bluetooth capability on your
bose
system that might be the definition of
privilege right there
i mean like wow wow but don't worry don
lemon is not privileged rachel lindsay
is not
they're victims they're victims in
american society and not only are they
victims they have the power to cancel
they've been given the power to cancel
despite the fact that they are making
presumably millions of dollars a year in
the case of don lemon
or rachel lindsay who is literally using
black lives matter to cut
ads for a cadillac capitalism always
wins number one is a lesson from this
but number two
it is amazing to see the purveyors of
canceled culture determined that they
who is privileged and who is not based
simply on skin color
while standing in a very expensive
outfit with an expensive purse it looks
like
in front of a cadillac xt6
bragging about how woke you are truly
amazing stuff there
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with an additional hour of content in
the meantime head on over to the michael
knowles show on today's episode mike
will be talking about how philadelphia
school honors black communism and black
power
that episode is available right now i'm
ben shapiro this is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas executive producer jeremy
boring
our supervising producers are mathis
glover and robert sterling
production manager pavo wydowski our
associate producers are rebecca doyle
and savannah dominguez the show is
edited by adam's psy events
audio is mixed by mike coromina hair and
makeup is by fabiola christina
production assistant jessica crams the
ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright 2021
climate alarmists insist that this
recent cold spell does not disprove
global warming cnn admits that joe biden
is sleepy and a new york city school is
calling for the abolition
of white people check it out on the
michael knowles show